en esta ocasión vamos a hablar sobre las
gráficas de aceleración contra el tiempo
ya que con respecto a las gráficas de
movimiento esta es probablemente zonas
más difíciles y esto es porque la
aceleración naturalmente es un concepto
abstracto y a muchas personas les cuesta
trabajo entenderlo y ahora la tenemos en
una gráfica y a muchas personas tampoco
les gustan las gráficas y otra razón es
que si queremos conocer el
comportamiento de un objeto digamos que
quiero saber el movimiento de mi perro
que se llama daisy y digamos que daisy
está acelerando si queremos conocer la
velocidad que tuvo de y si no podemos
encontrarla viendo directamente esta
gráfica a menos que tengamos información
extra por ejemplo si conocemos la
velocidad que tuvo de y si en cierto
momento y con eso podríamos usar esta
gráfica para calcular la velocidad que
tuvo de y si en otro momento que nos
puede decir esta gráfica con respecto al
movimiento de daisy
esta gráfica describe la aceleración de
racing a lo mejor estamos jugando a que
atrape la pelota y ella tiene la pelota
aquí se la voy a lanzar esperando que
suelte la pelota ya que la haya traído y
esta gráfica va a representar su
aceleración como leemos esta gráfica es
lo siguiente aquí nos dice que le sitúa
una aceleración de 2 metros por segundo
al cuadrado durante los primeros cuatro
segundos y después su aceleración bajó
hasta cero esto fue a los seis segundos
y después tenemos una aceleración
negativa hasta que tenemos un -3 a los
nueve segundos pero esta gráfica no nos
dice si está teniendo mayor velocidad o
menor velocidad como podemos calcular lo
bueno podemos deducir algunas cosas ya
que la aceleración está relacionada con
la velocidad
y podemos encontrar esta relación si
recordamos cómo está definida la
aceleración es el cambio de velocidad
entre el cambio en el tiempo y es así
como relacionamos nuestra velocidad con
la aceleración para despejar delta de
nos queda que el cambio de velocidad
sobre cierto intervalo de tiempo será la
aceleración durante ese intervalo de
tiempo x dicho intervalo de tiempo
cuando tiempo tardó esta aceleración y
esta es la clave para relacionar esta
gráfica con la velocidad
en otras palabras primero consideremos
estos primeros cuatro segundos entre los
cero y cuatro segundos
daisy tuvo una aceleración de dos metros
por segundo al cuadrado lo sustituye
aquí aquí tengo dos que es la
aceleración metros por segundo al
cuadrado por el cambio en el tiempo que
fue de cuatro segundos
nos queda 8 positivo y las unidades son
metros por segundo este segundo se
canceló con este otro segundo de aquí
así que el cambio en velocidad durante
los primeros cuatro segundos fue de ocho
metros por segundo y es positivo esta no
es la velocidad es el cambio en la
velocidad
quien nos va a decir esta región
diagonal si yo quisiera definir la
velocidad a los 6 segundos pues la
aceleración en este punto es de 2 en
este punto es de una es de 1 y la
aceleración en este punto es 0 esta
aceleración sigue cambiando como puede
encontrar su velocidad pero tenemos
suerte esta formula nos permite incluir
algo importante el aspecto geométrico de
estas gráficas que nos va a facilitar la
vida y la forma de hacer esto es que
observemos esta fórmula esto es igual a
a por delta t pero la aceleración que
pusimos es esta 2 durante los primeros 4
segundos la aceleración es de 2 del tate
fue de 4 tomamos este 2 lo multiplicamos
por este 4 y nos dio este número 8
positivo pero esto es una altura por una
base
y si multiplicamos una base por una
altura nos va a dar el área de un
rectángulo así que encontramos el área
de este rectángulo el área está dada por
delta b el área de un rectángulo es
altura por base sabemos que la altura
está representada por la aceleración y
la base va a estar representada por
delta t
y usando la definición de aceleración la
re acomodamos y sabemos a por delta t es
el cambio en la velocidad así que el
área y el cambio en la velocidad están
representando exactamente lo mismo en
esta gráfica el área es el cambio en la
velocidad y esto nos va a ser muy útil
porque cuando vemos esto el área seguirá
siendo el cambio en la velocidad y esto
ya me facilita cómo calcular el área de
esto el área de un triángulo es la mitad
de la altura por la base yo no sé cómo
calcular la aceleración directamente con
esta fórmula pero ahora ya sé cómo
encontrar el área por ejemplo esta área
es igual a un medio por la base que es
de 2 segundos la altura va a ser 2
positivos metros por segundo al cuadrado
y nos queda con que este 2 se cancela
con este 2 de arriba y esto es igual a 2
metros por segundo esta es el área de
este triángulo en esta gráfica y
representa el cambio en la velocidad así
que la velocidad de daisy cambio en dos
metros por segundo al menos durante este
tiempo y ustedes pueden no estar de
acuerdo pueden decirme a ver espérate
esto si te lo creo de que la base por la
altura es igual a la aceleración por
delta t pero en el triángulo tenemos un
factor extra que es este un medio y aquí
no tenemos ningún un medio como podemos
seguir haciendo esta afirmación pues
podemos usar esta afirmación haciendo lo
mismo que hemos hecho en otras ocasiones
imaginemos que aquí tenemos un
rectángulo vamos a estimar el área con
muchos rectángulos y estos rectángulos
lucen muy finitos no luce para nada como
el área de un triángulo sino que tenemos
estos pedazos extra aquí arriba y tienen
razón esto no funcionó muy bien
vamos a hacer rectángulos más delgados
con una base más chica hacemos este
rectángulo así este otro así otro más
así delgadito y vemos que estamos
mejorando esto se acerca mejor al área
del triángulo aunque aún no es exacto y
estoy de acuerdo vamos a hacer
rectángulos aún más delgados uno
delgadito aquí otro delgadito acá todos
estos tienen el mismo ancho pero son
mucho más delgados que los anteriores y
ahorita si nos estamos acercando un poco
más conforme hagamos más delgados los
rectángulos nos acercaremos cada vez más
a encontrar el área exacta del triángulo
la teoría es que si hacemos los
rectángulos infinitamente delgados nos
van a representar el área exactamente y
cada uno de ellos puede calcularse con
esta fórmula cada uno de ellos tendrá la
aceleración como parte de la altura del
rectángulo y uno
instante de tiempo infinitesimal como la
base y así encontraremos nuestra delta
be total que es el área de este
triángulo en pocas palabras el área en
una gráfica de aceleración contra el
tiempo representa el cambio en la
velocidad esto es algo que siempre
tienen que recordar porque es uno de los
aspectos más importantes en estas
gráficas de aceleración contra tiempo
muchas veces este es el aspecto más útil
de estas gráficas porque nos interesa el
cambio en la velocidad porque nos ayuda
a encontrar la velocidad solo
necesitamos encontrar la velocidad en un
punto para encontrar la velocidad en
cualquier punto
digamos que les doy la velocidad que
veis y tenían no sé por alguna razón
tenía un cronómetro conmigo inicié mi
cronómetro y tome nota del tiempo cuando
el tiempo era igual a cero daisy tenía
una velocidad de 1 metro por segundo
positivo esa era la velocidad de daisy
cuando comencé a tomarle el tiempo entre
igual a cero
puedo calcular la velocidad en cualquier
momento que yo quiera la velocidad que
tenía daisy a los 4 segundos para
encontrar la velocidad a los cuatro
segundos puedo decir que el cambio de
velocidad durante este periodo de tiempo
este valor ya lo encontré encontré que
era de ocho metros por segundo positivo
de esta vez tiene que ser igual a esto
más ocho metros por segundo y cuál es
del tv pues es nuestra vez a los cuatro
segundos menos la velocidad a los cero
segundos esto tiene que ser igual a 8
positivo metros por segundo bueno la
velocidad a los cero segundos era de un
metro por segundo lo sustituyó aquí esto
es menos un metro por segundo que es
igual a ocho metros por segundo positivo
por lo que la velocidad a los 4 segundos
es igual a 9 metros por segundo positivo
y vaya esto nos costó trabajo no
quisiera yo hacer esto cada vez que
quiere encontrar la velocidad
por suerte hay una forma más rápida de
hacerlo una vez que conocemos la
velocidad de inicio que en este ejemplo
fue de 1 cual fue nuestro cambio en la
velocidad pues fue de 8 positivo nuestra
velocidad final cuál fue pues 8 19
metros por segundo positivo vamos a
tomar este cambio en velocidad y a este
le vamos a sumar la velocidad inicial y
así obtendremos nuestra velocidad final
en ese tiempo por ejemplo si yo quiero
encontrar la velocidad a los 6 segundos
podemos decir que comenzamos con nuestra
ve a los 4 segundos que es una velocidad
de 9 positivo nuestro cambio fue 2
positivo
por lo que nos va a quedar que es 11
positivo metros por segundo y ustedes
pueden decir a ver espérame un momento
si tenemos delta b que es 2 positivo no
debería ser esta delta ve la de toda
esta área no debería ser ve a los 6
segundos menos ve a los 0 segundos y que
esto fuera igual a los 2 metros por
segundo
pues no no puedo hacer esto y la razón
por la que no lo puedo hacer es que
observen que de este lado izquierdo mi
intervalo va de 0 a 6 pero del lado
derecho de esta igualdad solo estoy
incluyendo el área del intervalo de 4 a
6 que es el área de este triángulo
amarillo si quiero poner aquí b6 ibex 0
de este otro lado lo puedo hacer pero
para mi área total tengo que usar
obviamente toda el área en otras
palabras el área total que va desde 0
hasta 6
y es lo que está definido en este lado
ambos lados tienen que ser congruentes
entre sí para conocer el área total pues
tengo esta área de mi rectángulo verde
que es 8 positivo y el área de mi
triángulo amarillo que es de 2 positivo
8 + 2 es 10 mi área total es de 10 y si
hago esto puedo decir que ves 6 es igual
me ve en 0 que dijimos que es 1
y nos queda que ve a los 6 segundos es
de 11 metros por segundo igual que el
resultado que encontramos anteriormente
puede resolverlo matemáticamente como lo
acabamos de ver pero siempre tienen que
tener cuidado de que la fórmula sea
congruente en ambos lados ahora
encontremos la última parte de esta
gráfica esta área y el área siempre va a
estar contenida desde la curva hacia el
eje así que en este caso nuestra área
está por debajo del eje por lo que va a
ser una área negativa nuevamente es un
triángulo su área es un medio por la
base por la altura un medio por la base
que es 123
segundos
y la altura es menos 3
menos tres metros por segundo al
cuadrado por lo que el área total va a
ser menos 4.5
metros por segundo y ahora de si va a
tener un cambio de velocidad de menos
4.5 metros por segundo al cuadrado si
queremos encontrar la velocidad a los
nueve segundos hay varias formas en las
que podemos encontrarlo conceptualmente
podemos decir que daisy comenzó a los
seis segundos con una velocidad de 11 su
cambio durante este periodo fue de menos
4.5 y si sumamos ambos nos va a quedar
6.5 positivo ya que estoy sumando 11 y
menos 4.5 metros por segundo y si estos
o no a alguna brujería matemática
podemos decir que nuestra delta b es
igual a menos 4.5 metros por segundo y
delta b va a ser y aquí tenemos que
tener cuidado este menos 4.5 representa
este triángulo de aquí abajo por lo que
tiene que ser la del tav entre 6 y 9 de
9 menos de 6 es igual a menos 4.5 metros
x
por lo que ve 9 - nuestra ve a las 6 ya
sabemos cuáles encontramos que fue de 11
aquí tengo menos 11 igual a menos 4.5
metros por segundo
ve a los 9 segundos va a ser igual a qué
es lo que obtuvimos aquí arriba 6.5
metros por segundo positivo así que el
encontrar el área nos va a dar el cambio
en la velocidad y el tener el cambio en
la velocidad y al tener la velocidad en
un punto en el tiempo podremos encontrar
la velocidad en cualquier otro momento
del tiempo aunque tengan cuidado
asegúrense de que están asociando el
intervalo de tiempo correcto tanto en el
lado izquierdo como en el lado derecho
de la igualdad
una cosa antes de terminar la pendiente
en estas gráficas usualmente representan
algo importante
veamos qué significa la pendiente en
esta gráfica la pendiente siempre
representa el cambio vertical dividido
por el cambio horizontal el cambio
vertical es de 2 menos de 1 / x2 x 1
excepto que en lugar de tener x y
tenemos la aceleración y el tiempo
tenemos a 2 menos a 1 entre t 2 menos de
1 esto va a ser de alta a el cambio en
la aceleración entre el cambio en el
tiempo y que es esto es la tasa de
cambio de la aceleración y esto es un
pasito más complicado de lo que habíamos
visto la velocidad es el cambio en la
posición durante el cambio en el tiempo
la aceleración es el cambio de velocidad
durante el cambio en el tiempo
y ahora decimos que algo es el cambio en
la aceleración durante el cambio en el
tiempo conocido como sobre aceleración o
tirón aunque no es un término muy usado
y para ser honestos no es la variable de
movimiento más usada y tampoco es una
variable de la que les vayan a hacer
muchas preguntas en sus cursos pero a
veces tiene sus aplicaciones existe y
tiene su nombre sobre aceleración o
tirón en resumen lo importante aquí es
que el área en una gráfica de
aceleración contra tiempo nos da el
cambio en la velocidad y ya que
conocemos la velocidad en un punto
podemos conocer la velocidad en
cualquier otro punto y la pendiente en
una gráfica de aceleración contra tiempo
nos da la sobre aceleración o tirón